welcome back or we're now on problem
number eleven eleven and this says the
circle above has center o
and diameter a B and it's a dotted line
in the book but I made it a solid green
line the two semicircles have diameters
Oh a so this is one semicircle and this
is its diameter Oh a and then OB this is
the other semicircle its OB if the
circumference of the circle is 36 PI so
circumference of the circle of the big
circle and actually I'll do it in yellow
which is the color of kind of the
perimeter or the circumference of that
circle so they saying the circumference
is 36 PI what is the length of the
curved path from a be to O so they want
to figure out the length of essentially
this brown path that's before we break
into the math just how can we think
about this well we have a big circle and
we know it's circumference so if we know
it's circumference we could figure out
its radius or diameter right because you
know the formula circumference is equal
to 2 pi R right so if we know the
circumference of this big circle we can
actually figure out its radius by using
this formula and the radius of the big
circle which would be let's say Oh a or
OB they're both radiuses of the big
circle then those are the diameter of
each of these each of these half circles
reach of these semi circles right so if
we know that this if we know this
diameter we could you know take half of
it and reuse this formula or say that
circumference is 2 is pi times the
diameter we could do either one and we
could figure out if we let's say we know
let's say we know this radius and we
could figure out this then we could
figure out the circumference of this
larger circle and I'll actually make the
claim that the circumference of this
larger circle is the same as a
circumference of this half circle Plus
this half circle I think you know why
you can just if you just shifted this up
then you would get the other half of
this circle right the other way you
could have done is you figure out the
circumference of this circle divide by 2
to get this take the circumference of
this circle divide by 2 to get
and then Adam but you'll get the same
thing just as the circumference of this
circle so let's do the problem
so circumference is equal to 2 PI R we
know the circumference of the larger
circle is 36 PI so let's see 36 PI
whoops 36 pi is equal to 2 pi R divide
both sides by 2 pi and I'll switch the
sides too so you get R is equal to 36 PI
over 2 pi right I just divided both
sides by 2 pi PI's cancel out 36 divided
by 2 is equal to 18
and so what's 18 18 is this is this
length right here 18 right is this
length we just figure out that's the
radius of the larger circle and now we
could use this which is the diameter of
the smaller circle to figure out its
circumference using the same formula and
now I'm going to use Brown for this this
circumference so circumference is equal
to 2 PI R that's the same thing as
because 2 times the radius is the
diameter right so that equals pi times
the diameter we know what the diameter
is the diameter is 18 right so we could
say circumference is equal to PI times
the diameter diameter is 18 or if we
rearrange that that's 18 pi and we're
done
because what we just figured out is the
circumference of this larger circle we
could take it we could divide it by 2
and figure out well this is we could say
that this is 9 pi right here just this
piece this piece is 9 pi and if we do
the same math here on this piece we
would also get 9 pi but that's just
that's also adds up to 18 pi
hopefully you understand what I'm saying
let's move on to the next problem image
clear image invert colors all right so
in the table above this is our classic X
f of X table f of X when x is 0 f of X
is a when X is 1 f of X is 24 when X is
2
f of X is B and says the table above
shows some values of the functions of f
f is a linear function so what does a
linear function mean linear means it's a
line right and that also means that the
slope is constant if you haven't gotten
well if you haven't gotten past algebra
one you probably haven't seen functions
with non constant slopes but like for
example quadratics don't have constant
slopes the linear means that the slope
is constant
alright that's that's the one conclusion
you can make from that statement and
then they want to know what is the value
of a plus B a plus B is what so the only
thing we know is this table and we know
that it's linear and linear means that
the slope is constant so the slope is
constant so let's see what we can figure
out the slope so that means the slope
from from X is equal to 0 to X is equal
to 1 is the same as the slope from X is
equal to 1 to X is equal to 2 so what's
the slope if we use these two terms
slope is changing well change in f of X
over change in X right so change in so
change in I means change in Y over
change in X right we could we could call
this Y instead so change in Y we take
the end let's see 24 minus a you might
want to review the slope video if you
forgot this 24 minus a over the change
in X is 1 minus 0 well that's just 1 so
that equals 24 minus a right and what's
the what's the slope from these points
cuz we know it's constant we know the
slope from between these two points is
going to be the same as the slope
between these two points well we do the
same thing we take the endpoints change
in Y so it's B minus 24 over change in X
2 minus 1 so that equals well this is
just 1 so that is equals B minus 24 so
this is the slope between the second two
points and this is the slope between the
first two points and since we know it's
linear since we know this is a linear
equation we can say well they must be
equal to each other so let's see if that
gets us to where we want to
so we know that 24 minus a is equal to B
minus 24 right let's see let let's
subtract let's add to 24 to both sides
you get 48 minus a is equal to B right I
just added 24 to both sides and if we
add a to both sides I see the endpoint
48 is equal to a plus B and that is
choice C let us move on and remember all
we did we use this information and we
use the fact that slope is constant so
the only thing that you would have had
to know ahead of time is the equation of
us of us of the slope and that's just
change in Y over change in X and that
linear means constant slope
Mich clear image invert colors all right
so they write a little sequence up here
this is let's see number 13 it's 3 5
negative 5 they say the first term of
the sequence of the numbers shown is 3
that's obvious they'd show that each
even number term is 2 more than the
previous term so right from we go from 3
to 5 that was 2 more right because isn't
this is the second term so it's an even
number term so this is 2 more and each
odd number of terms after the first is
minus 1 times the previous so right
minus 1 minus 1 times this term is minus
5 so that's what they're saying for
example the second term is 3 plus 2
right and the third term is minus 1
times 5 what is the 55th erm of the
sequence so on the SAT whenever you know
they ask you some crazy term like the
hundredth term or the 55th term that's a
huge signal that that this sequence is
probably going to repeat itself and you
just have to figure out the pattern and
then once you know that pattern I'll
show you how to figure out the 500th
term if you have to so let's let's just
with any sequence the best thing to do
is just write out a bunch of term so we
start at 3 we add 2 we get 5 we multiply
that by negative 1 right this is plus 2
let me multiply by negative 1 times
negative 1 we get minus 5
then we want to add 2 so 2 times 2 times
negative 5 is I don't know foot but
we're adding 2 right 2 plus negative 5
is minus 3 I think I'm already seeing a
pattern here do and then we have to
multiply that times minus 1 times minus
1 that's not X minus 1 this is x minus 1
so minus 1 times 3 huh no we're all used
to X now so minus 1 times 3 I should do
- one time instead - 1 times 3 well
that's 3 and then we add 2 to it plus 2
we get 5 and it's interesting then it's
going to start repeating minus 1 is
minus 5 so let's see what the what the
repetition looks like the first term is
3 the second term is 5 the third term is
minus 5 the fourth term is is minus 3
the fifth term is 3 again 6 therm is 5/7
and so on
oh I'm almost out of time I'll continue
this in the next video